first of all you got great eyes if you
read everything that's on this label
it says absolute cleanliness is
godliness
so you know i like that
peace what's up gq i'm common and these
are my essentials
my first item is my bible it just
reminds me of what i'm
here to do and what i'm supposed to do
and and remembering god's love and the
word of god has always been
like the key to who i am my mother
sent me this this bible i eventually
because i travel a lot
said i got to get another one because i
want to keep the one that she got me
just
at home so this is a
another version of what what i
originally got from my mother
i really take this everywhere with me
and do my best to live it so that's why
this is
definitely an essential
one of my essentials is essentia i grew
up drinking
not a lot of water drink kool-aid
pot or soda and some people say
basically everything but what
the more i started working the more i
started
wanting to take care of myself the more
energy i needed us
i would find out information about
things that i could do to be healthier
to be better
i started drinking water more and more
started feeling more and more like
black superman you understand it really
is truly one of the essentials that i
no matter where i am i'm you know
going to find my water and accenture is
one of the brands that i really like
i try to get two to three bottles in a
day a lot of people that know me be like
why is this dude going to the bathroom
that much when you drinking that much
water
it happens now this palo santo
if you smell this then you know common
is somewhere in the area
i'll be like in a building like about to
do a speech
or do something um something important
to performance
and i like the palo santo now what palo
santo means is holy wood
and it comes from somewhere in south
america
and i honestly just got on the palo
santo maybe a
year and a half two years ago i started
using it
and man i i'm i'm like into it it's just
it brings in good energy and removes the
bad energy i'll be on zoom meetings
and the smoke will be going up and i'll
be like i know they think i'm smoking
right now but i'm not smoking it's palo
santo
so it's how you smell it you know i'm
around
green drink you know some people do
coffee
this is my coffee it has cucumber
seasonal greens kale this has coconut
water too um lime and spirulina
man i'm i'm all into it i'll be like on
set
and because i can't eat a meal i drink
this and this
this is like me having my coffee like
i'm gonna drink a little bit now
now my next item is dr broner's
i love it i use it you know as
in for showers and baths but i also use
it
you know just you know washing my hands
they've been around making this soap
since 1858
it's pretty crazy but it's some good
soap she says
teach the moral abc that unites all
mankind
but it's also like godliness i like you
know when people put
almost like affirmations on their
products
it's something about that that i i dig
and um
yeah then it's um natural like it's it's
not it ain't got all that bs in it so
i love dr brones what's an essential
if you don't have snacks you have to
have some snacks
they taste like potato chips listen i'm
vegan
so i eat pretty healthy overall
um so even when i'm eating these cassava
chips i feel like
they like it's not the worst of the
worst
they're gluten-free they're vegan
whatever they good
i get these two people who eat
everything and they like
damn these are good and they got
different flavors too my
my favorite is sea salt i've drank a lot
of wine for some reason
you drink wine and then you start
getting hungry i wake up in the morning
chips is all on the couch but that's
life
he's a cassava chip
[Music]
candles just create a vibe i use candles
in in
studios um i have candles
in my dressing rooms i have candles um
in my home
candles you know i love lighting candles
something that
that it's just i don't know it has the
energy to it a spirit to it i have a
candle
you all can't see i'll bring another
candle in that that's lit right here
it says peace and tranquility you know
i'm the candle man
a lot of my essentials as you can see um
kind of
fall under like
positive affirmations and energy like
progress
joy love and creativity um things that i
you know want to base my life in so i
always keep these candles i got one
behind me it says abundance like i light
them all the time
so this is like my lotion this cream is
it's almond cookie
and i know it sounds like some men you
might feel like i'm in cookie you think
i'm gonna wear almond cookie
well let me tell you women definitely
enjoy
my smell and part of it is almond cookie
i hate so don't trip
anyway i love it it's necessary it's an
essential
like there's times when i'm doing photo
shoots with my ankles showing
can't have ashy ankles man people notice
that yeah
they doing be like damn dude is ashy i
make sure
that i'm straight with this keep it
fresh and i take it everywhere
now you're wondering what this is it was
one
time last year i lost my voice
but i needed to be recording but my
voice was gone for like a week and a
half two
two weeks the air in those and throw
specialists tell me
hey i have a vocal coach you need to go
to she will help you get your
your vocal back and she said look this
is something i give to my vocalist
to do before their performances um it
kind of clears out
your vocal chords and like you know
allows you to perform
vocally at your best it worked i was
like yeah
this is all right she usually does it
with singers you has a straw to
to like hit notes
[Music]
and it opens your vocals up also my
voice is an instrument so
i take care of that instrument now so
now even when i'm not dealing with
any type of vocal issues i go out there
like a professional
some mc's like man that ain't hip-hop
yes it is hip-hop
hip-hop goes where we go i'm talking
about it my voice
need to be clear you're like yeah you're
like man you need to try a new technique
huh
this is one of my routines it's an
essential it's a wellness shot
i take this immunity like shot because
man that immune system is especially
traveling a lot and
being around a lot of people or just in
general like our immune systems
we want them to be at full capacity um
this one has ginger
bee pollen cayenne
and and little orange juice and turmeric
oh yes
oh man turmeric is one of the best
things you can have
and it's you know it's one of those
things when somebody first tried they
like
man like but eventually you you become
acclimated and it's you know it's normal
it just is
[Music]
another essential is to have a vegan
chef
we call it cam comichi is a incredible
chef um
very talented she's from houston so she
cooks vegan food but it's really
like i have a variety of foods i'm
eating
good stuff like i'm eating really good
she'll do like a cheese steak
a vegan cheese steak like vegan fried
chicken
but then you know i also just eat some
regular sandwiches and good food man
this is good
simple as that and it's clean um so i'm
eating good
and still i don't be like laid out as
soon as i eat but
because i like to eat at a certain point
in my life i decided to eat
you know vegan and i'd rather invest in
myself
like in my wellness than to go out there
and just get
three cars and go five cars and
you know some stuff that i don't really
need like i'd rather feel good
and eat good than just have you know
some material things that don't mean as
much to me
and it's reinvesting and taking care of
myself
and enjoying good food
all right gq this is common those are my
essentials
y'all know my credentials peace